there's this idea in our society that we
need to have a totally open classroom
don't ban anything just be open to all
ideas well that's crazy you have to ban
certain ideas you have to leave them out
of the curriculum there are only so many
weeks in a semester every second that
you waste reading Tony easy coats and
Kimberly Rancho is a second that you're
not reading a real historian that you're
not reading I don't know Shakespeare
that you're you're not reading Tolstoy
you're not reading writers who are
valuable who will edify you and who will
make you more educated every second that
you waste in a math classroom being
taught the two plus two equals five is
the second that you're not being taught
the truth which is that two plus two
equals four we have to ban two plus two
equals five out of the classroom and we
need to limit our curricula to things
that will actually educate students